Speaker 1: in the midst of all of what is
going on, including with the covid spikes
and so many other things which we will talk
about today.
President Joe Biden's approval is soaring
among independents.
It is remaining high among Democrats, it is
remaining low among Republicans, but it is
increasing dramatically among independents
and also specifically on the issue of covid
handling, which now Donald Trump himself and
many Republicans are actively antagonizing
the Biden administration over which we will
also talk about today.
Joe Biden getting, as Donald Trump likes to
say, very high marks when it comes to the
handling of the pandemic.
So let's look at a couple of articles about
these polls.
First of all, Newsweek, Joe Biden's approval
rating soaring among independents.
Joe Biden's approval rating among independents
has soared following a sharp decline at the
end of June.
According to an Ipsos survey.
The Ipsos weekly approval tracker found that
Biden's rating among independents stood at
fifty two in the latest survey.
The president's overall approval rating is
fifty three.
Disapproval is forty two.
Biden enjoys 88 percent approval among Democrats.
That's very close to within the margin of
error, down from ninety one.
That's down three points.
But the margin of error is three and a half.
Approval among Republicans is up very slightly,
13 to 17, but the approval figure from independent
voters is up sharply.
It hit the last time Biden's approval among
independents hit 50 percent was June 17th.
He was down to 45 percent.
Then he was down to 34 percent among independents
at the beginning of July.
That's the lowest in the survey since Biden
took office.
And then it recovered to forty four and now
to fifty two.
Why the president enjoys high approval from
independents on covid pandemic with fifty
nine percent approval, which is in line with
his overall approval.
That is a very, very good sign.
Opinions on the president's performance follow
party lines.
Eighty six percent of Democrats approve on
his covid approach, compared to just thirty
three percent of Republicans.
But I will tell you, 33 percent approval on
covid from Republicans when they are the covid
is being used as a weapon against Joe Biden
by Republicans to say we can't trust the vaccines,
which Trump is now saying we will get to,
that the two authoritarian when it comes to
masking or of vaccines or whatever the case
to still have one in three Republicans support
you when Distin.
Information is this weaponized?
I actually think is still notable in some
sense.
Let's look at more data here.
Biden gets sixty six percent approval from
Americans in pandemic handling.
This is from a CBS News YouGov poll.
26 percent of Americans believe Biden is doing
a very good job at managing the pandemic,
but another 40 percent think he's doing a
somewhat good job.
Only 34 percent disapprove of Biden's covid
handling.
Only 18 percent call it very bad.
People said the country as a whole is doing
a better job now at getting the covid the
coronavirus under control than what was going
on in January.
Polling from January and July flipflopped
64 percent now believe the pandemic is going
well.
Only 35 percent believed that it was going
well back in January.
So there's a few different takeaways here
and important things.
First of all, when you go to Republicans and
you say, well, what what how do you explain
this?
It seems even through your propaganda.
Joe Biden is doing well, particularly on this.
Many of them will say, have you seen Joe Biden's
YouTube live streams and have you seen the
downvotes?
There's often, you know, like two hundred
likes and three thousand dislikes.
When Joe Biden live streams, it is of no meaning
or value at all.
This is what Republicans are doing.
They what they call they call it brigading
or ratio in Joe Biden's live streams and they
dislike them.
It's not even a serious part of the conversation,
but that's what they will say.
Part of the reason that Joe Biden's approval
isn't higher is that it has been a right wing
media concerted effort since Joe Biden was
sworn in to simply assassinate character and
make wild allegations about Joe Biden being
a Marxist, communist, dictatorial, authoritarian
right wing media used to be eighty five percent
about character assassination and lies.
It's now ninety nine percent about character
assassination and lies.
It's been a desperate race to see who can
come up with the most outrageous lie about
the Democrat Party and Socialist Biden, in
part maybe because of the vacuum created by
the death of Rush Limbaugh among right wing
media.
Now, I do think there are some independents
who maybe thought the lies about Joe Biden
were true.
Maybe Joe Biden was going to take their guns.
Maybe Joe Biden was going to force them to
be vague, and maybe Joe Biden was going to
force them to, you know, I don't know, flush
toilets 10 or 15 times or
Speaker 2: flushing toilets 10 times, 15 times.
Right.
Speaker 1: And it's not happening.
And some of those independents are actually
saying, oh, you know what?
Maybe maybe that was crazy.
And I never should have believed that.
And Joe Biden's actually doing OK as far as
Republicans go.
Many of them are too far gone and too, too
indoctrinated to change their views.
But there seem to be independents that can
see reason.
And they're coming over to say, I approve
of Joe Biden and I approve of Joe Biden's
handling of some issues.
Now, the implications here are twofold.
The immediate implications continue to be
what is the impact on people simply getting
vaccinated because we're having trouble vaccinating
our way out of the out of the pandemic because
of half of Republicans who don't want to get
that vaccine.
That's the immediate question.
In terms of electorally, I think it's too
early to take this information about Biden's
approval and say anything about twenty, twenty
four.
We don't even know if Joe Biden is running
in twenty twenty four.
It's just too early.
It doesn't tell us anything, but we are starting
to be able to glean some things about twenty,
twenty two typically in twenty, twenty two
based on history.
As we talked with Rachel, bit of cougher almost
exclusively, you would expect Democrats to
do poorly in the House, maybe in the Senate.
That's the way it tends to go.
Party takes the White House two years later.
They do poorly in the midterms.
However, it may not be that way if Joe Biden
continues to have.
What is this?
You know, in the modern historical context,
a high approval rating.
Republicans really need swing voters to do
well in twenty twenty two.
The fact that independents are the group that
is most heavily shifting from being against
Joe Biden to being in favor of him, approving
of him, that's not a particularly good sign
for Republicans.
Now, their answer might be, let's just suppress
even more of the vote.
And they're trying to do that by proposing
more than two hundred and fifty voter suppression
bills across forty something states.
So we are starting to be able to talk about
twenty, twenty two, but still a long way to
go before I would be comfortable saying I
think it'll probably be OK for Democrats or
it could be a bloodbath for Democrats.
We don't know yet.
We will have a clearer picture, I think, as
we close in on September where the twenty
twenty two races are expected to start getting
going early.
And speaking of by September, mid-August,
August 16th, listen to this.
It's The David Pakman Show 16th anniversary.
16TH anniversary, August 16th, we are going
to be doing a one day membership blowout on
that day.
I really hope that if you've enjoyed the show
or even if you don't, but you think there's
some value in it existing, you can dislike
me.
But maybe you think the show has some value,
some redeeming quality, some redemptive quality.
Please get on my newsletter at David Pakman
Dotcom, because on August 16th, you'll get
an email telling you how to take advantage
of a one day outrageous, outrageous membership
special.
We'll take a quick break.
Send me your thoughts about independents shifting
to Biden on Twitter, where you can find me
at the Pakman.
Remember that we do have an extra show that
we do every day, if you like this show enough
to want more of it, like if you're one of
the rare folks who's like, oh, you know what,
an hour a day is actually not enough of this
nonsense.
We do an extra 15 to 20 minutes minutes for
our paid subscribers, just become a member
at join Pakman Dotcom and you'll get instant
access to what we call the bonus show.